the playstation 5 ui has been revealed
so let's go over nine of the biggest
changes number one the game is always
front and center the ps5 ui has received
a complete overhaul and the most
noticeable change is the literal
emphasis on your game being front and
center once you boot up the ps5 from
rest mode your game will be up and
running from wherever you last left off
accompanied by the all-new control
center
whether you're scrolling through recent
activity joining chat rooms sharing
screenshots or checking the news it all
occurs overlaid on the game you're
actively playing
meaning your gaming experience isn't
being entirely interrupted by the
console forcing you into another menu
like the ps4 currently does number two
the control center pressing the
playstation button now brings you to the
ps5 control center previously with the
ps4 tapping the ps button would bring
you out of the game into the ps4's home
screen if you held it it'd bring up the
quick menu where you could check
notifications friendless and all that
jazz this time around pressing the ps5
ps button no longer interrupts the game
but brings us to its new card based ui
instead of having to navigate either the
home screen or quick menu everything you
want to accomplish from checking on your
friends list to going over game activity
or looking at notifications happens in
the control center using cards
it's time to say goodbye to the home and
quick menu from the ps4 all together
number three cards cards are a new and
major integration into how we'll be
navigating the console's ui
cards give you a glimpse in everything
going on like news game activity and
what your friends are up to and it'll
have unique integration into certain ps5
games the big card based feature is
activities which are a way to track what
you have and haven't done within the
game you're playing that's kind of like
the playstation's very own quest log
this is a nifty feature for
completionists and trophy hunters as
it's a quick way to get a bird's eye
view of what you haven't done yet in a
game such as showing objectives you
haven't completed yet or even
teleporting you in the game to a
specific objective it even gives you an
idea of how long it'll take to achieve
that objective so say you have to call
your mom in a half an hour this feature
gives you a quick look into how much
time you'll actually need to complete
your objective rather than having to
stop halfway through unfulfilled and
anxious through the entire conversation
with your mom because you're thinking
about wanting to get back to it giving a
new and literal meaning to saying just
two more minutes to the nagging sibling
parent dog whatever
number four picture in picture cards can
also be placed on the screen while
you're playing either snapping to
certain sides or working as picture in
picture you'll be able to view
objectives from your activity list
directly on screen without having to
interrupt your game and maneuver other
menu screens there's also a new game
help feature for active playstation plus
members that offers in-game guidance to
achieve certain goals like giving you
hints with screenshots and videos and it
can be snapped on the screen alongside
your game so you don't have to leave and
go searching online for a walkthrough
number five friend stuff continuing the
emphasis on keeping the game front and
center now when friends invite you to
chat rooms you can do it all with your
game running in the background
previously with the ps4 getting an
invitation would interrupt your game
requiring you to go to another menu
screen where you'd enter chat but no
more
additionally interacting with your
friends like hopping into their games
inviting them to chat rooms or sharing a
screenshot with them can all be done
through cards in the control center
including the share screen option the
card feature lets you snap a live feed
of their gameplay on your screen so now
you can watch your friends get destroyed
to demon souls while you gallantly swing
through nyc in spider-man miles morales
number six the create button
zero interruption is the name of the
game here in the ps5's ui and pressing
the create button brings up a minimalist
option bar at the bottom of the screen
with the option to capture something
that had just happened a screenshot or
begin recording gameplay number 7 the
home screen while there's a lot of talk
of its control center and card ui the
home screen of course makes a return but
with a facelift no less if you're
starting your console up fresh the home
screen is where you'll land it's where
you'll go if you want to start another
game or download a new one
this time around media has its own
separate menu from games rather than
being all bunched together like on the
ps4
each game and application has its own
integrated hub to explore information
which is a much needed upgrade to the
ps4's feature of pressing down on a game
and getting a bunched up convoluted look
at news trophies and friend activity
this new design seems much more
breathable number eight explore explore
is a new option to the ps5 that brings
together all of your games shows news
stories and trending media however the
feature is still being tested out so
just be aware that it won't be available
to every user on day one number nine the
playstation store playstation store is
now integrated in the menu experience as
opposed to being its own separate app
making exploring shopping and finding
new games a quicker more intuitive
experience without ever having to leave
the ps5's home screen there's nine of
the biggest changes we saw from the ps5
ui needless to say it's entirely
different and we'll of course know a lot
more once we get hands on with the thing
so keep your eyes here on gamespot and
while you're at it check out generation
next it's the show about next generation
consoles this was kurt happy gaming tell
someone you love them
[Music]
you